The ... Hallo und herzlich willkommen zum Humorpodcast, zum Spaßpodcast. Sie darf gelacht werden, sie darf sich amüsiert werden, das Podcast-Ufo mit mir, Stefan Tietze und dir, Florian Tienwil und euch. Richtig, ihr seid auch dabei, Ulk ist dabei und natürlich aus der anonymen Masse von Zuhörern sticht besonders heraus Daniel für dieses tolle Intro. Vielen, vielen Dank, dass den Ton setzt. Der Ton wurde gesetzt und jetzt darf aber auch wieder gelacht werden. Es darf Spaß gehabt, Glück gehabt werden.
Ihr habt euch jetzt eine Woche zurückgehalten, eine Woche habt ihr euch zusammengekniffen, habt auf eure Mundwinkel gebissen, jedes Mal, wenn irgendwas lustiges passiert ist. Das hört auf, ihr dürft jetzt lautlos prusten zur kommenden Unterhaltungsshow mit Stefan Titzel. Titzel und Florentin Wli. Du hast geheiratet, du hast Frau Titzel geheiratet und hast dich entschieden, ihr Namen anzunehmen und er heisst Stefan Titzel. Und es wird einige Monate dauern, bis diese Verwirrung sich aufgelöst hat. Titzel Titzel war mein Vorschlag, aber das war ihr dann zu peinlich. Kann einer einen Doppelnamen annehmen und der andere nicht? Ich glaube, alles ist möglich. Ich glaube, dieses gesamte feudale Heiratssystem wurde komplett über den Haufen geworfen. Sind wir in diesem postmodernen Alles-ist-Möglich-Zeiten, von denen wir alle gesprochen haben? Ich glaube, du kannst auch tauschen. Also du kannst auch dann den Nachnamen deiner Frau nehmen und die Frau kriegt deinen Nachnamen. Das finde ich unscheiss. Und einfach alles. So ein Trading-Card-Game daraus zu machen. Ja, call me by your name, wo man den Namen tauscht. Das ist eigentlich sehr moderne Romantik, zu sagen, man wechselt den Nachnamen. Aber auf der anderen Seite, mittlerweile muss die Frau ja nicht mehr notwendigerweise den Namen des Mannes übernehmen, sondern man darf mildwischen, wildmischen, Entschuldigung. Ne, wow. Kleiner freudscher Versprung. Kleiner intrinsischer Gag. Man darf mildwischen. Und genau das meinen wir, meine Damen und Herren. Hier darf gelacht werden, hier darf Spaß werden. Genau, das sind die Momente, in denen sie jetzt drei, zwei, eins lachen. Lachen, da darf ein bisschen Druck abgebaut werden. Aber was ich mir dachte ist, dadurch, dass jetzt jeder die Nachnamen nur nehmen darf, den er möchte, werden ja irgendwann die richtig peinlichen, dummen, schlechten Nachnamen rausgefiltert werden aus dem System. Und wo bleibt denn dann noch der Spaß? Das freu ich mich. Wo kann ich mich dann, wenn ich über die Friedhöfe der Welt laufe und auf die Grabsteine zeige, lautlos prusten? Ja, Schnabelmann, Schnanowski, Peniswängler, irgendwie sowas. Penismann, wo sind denn diese ganzen Namen dann? Ja, die werden dann da rausgefiltert, weil wenn eine Frau den Herrn Penismann heiratet, kann sie einfach sagen, nee, ich will weiterhin meinen Namen benutzen. Ich will weiterhin meinen Namen, Vagina-Frau benutzen. Genau, das heißt, es wird sich immer weiter dazu entwickeln, dass die coolen Namen... Ich fand jetzt schon auch, ich habe die WM gesehen und dachte mir, die haben alle so coole Nachnamen, die deutschen Spieler.
Da gibt es nicht irgendwie so einen Schnitzelmeister oder so einen Gabrodski oder irgendwie sowas. Auch der Schweinsteiger ist nicht mehr dabei.
Alle die ganzen Namen, wo man dachte, ja, das ist ein original deutscher Name, da macht es auch nur Spaß, wenn der englische Kommentator sich die Zunge verstaucht beim Aussprechen. Heute gar nicht mehr. Deswegen, ich sehe das mit einem viel geschärften Schwert, diese Entwicklung, ob das so gut ist, dass man die albernen Nachnamen raushimmt aus einer Gesellschaft. Aber gerade aus dem Kontext genommen klingt es so ein bisschen so, wo sind die richtigen deutschen Namen, Florentin will. Bei der EM habe ich die richtigen deutschen Namen vermisst. Können ja mal, als wenn die Journalist sind, mal überlegen, ob er das einfach so auskoppelt. Nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, das meine ich nicht. Ich meine nur, das vielleicht, vielleicht auch unkürzelt. Es ist sehr warm hier drin. Es ist sehr, sehr warm hier drin, tatsächlich. Geht ehrlich gesagt. Aber dann auch stehen lassen. Aber dann auch einfach. Nee, apropos Deutsch, richtig schön Deutsch, ich war in Bayreuth. Ach, schön. Ich war in fucking Bayreuth. Man merkt schon irgendwie, ich komme immer hier rein in den Raum und merke immer schon ein bisschen, welche Phase Stefan hat. Also manchmal ist er der blaue Power Ranger, manchmal ist er der gelbe Power Ranger. Und man merkt schon, wenn man reinkommt, auch bevor er sagt, jetzt ist er gerade in so einem Wagner-Modus, überall kommen Haas mit rein, wo keiner reingehört, überall ist er schon mit drin, diese grosse Epik, da ist er einfach drin, man merkt schon so ein bisschen. Epikness, wenn ich laut spreche. Und einen jüdischen Kollegen fertig runtergemacht habe. Nee, also, ich war in Bayreuth, das war ein fantastischer Trip. Bei den Wagner-Festspielen. Bei den Wagner-Festspielen. Wo sich die geistige und finanzielle Elite Deutschlands trifft. Wo sich, machen wir uns jetzt vor, die finanzielle Elite Deutschlands trifft. Und zu der du mittlerweile auch gehörst. Nein, nein, nein. Dank der vielen T-Shirt-Verkäufe ist Stefan Tietze mit dabei. Nee, ich habe nämlich vielen lieben Dank an den Mann in Laudenbach. Den kennst du nämlich auch noch, weil wir haben zusammen damals beim Neo Magazin zusammengearbeitet, er war nämlich der Scherzanwalt Doktor Christian Witz.
Genau, ja.
Und wir haben auch viele andere Sachen gemacht, er war auch der Snackbär in dem Sketch von uns, den wir damals auch gemacht haben. Ja, stimmt, großartig, wo er in diesem Bärenkostüm war. Und der Kostümmer, also generell nichts gesehen hat, geschwitzt hat, grauenvollerreh. Und er spielt eine wirklich tragende Rolle im Tannhäuser, der er 2019 primär gefeiert hat.
Das war jetzt das zweite Spieljahr, weil es einmal Corona-Bringend ausfiel.
Und dann habe ich ihn auf dem Sommerfest getroffen und habe gefragt,
habe ich gesehen, dass du mitmachst, ich bin ein großer Fan.
Und jetzt hat er mir dann zusammen mit einem Kumpel die Reise ermöglicht und ich war da. Und wie cool ist das denn, mit einem Darsteller die ganze Zeit da rumzulaufen und mal den grünen Hügel mit so einer Inside-Perspektive zu bekommen. Und das war wirklich einfach nur fantastisch. Deswegen vielen, vielen Dank an Manni, der ja auch damals bei Gute-Arbeit mitgemacht hat, der überall mitgemacht hat und immer viel Spaß zu haben war. Und auch in dieser sehr weirden Performance vom Tannhäuser, die fantastisch war. Das muss ein Schauspieler auch können, einfach so eine gewisse Reichweite haben. Einfach mit einer Wagner-Oper mitzuspielen, aber auch einfach in dem Bärenkostüm den Snackbären zu spielen. Einer der lustigsten Drehs für mich, wahrscheinlich unerträglich für ihn, aber sehr lustig, weil es gab eine Szene, wo wir den Snackbär ausfindig gemacht haben, dieses Snackbox, wo niemand was dafür zahlt. Und dann musste ich ihm so eine Box übergeben, wo das Geld drin war, das gesammelt wurde, viel zu wenig Geld. Aber er hat in seinem Kostüm nichts gesehen. Das heißt, diese Szene war für mich so wahnsinnig lustig, weil ich immer ihm diese Box gereicht habe, so hier ist das Geld. Und er hat es einfach nicht gesehen und musste irgendwo mit seinen riesigen Pfoten hingreifen und mit beiden fingerlosen Tatzen, also wirklich unmöglich,
das irgendwie greifen. Und allein dieser
Moment, wenn du jemandem was reichst und der
einfach nicht reagiert,
das war wirklich ein Moment, wo ich Schwierigkeiten hatte,
durch die Szene zu kommen, weil das so witzig war,
wie er einfach völlig fertig
in diesem Bärenkostüm war. Also toll.
Toller Sketch, kann man sich gerne
nochmal angucken, der Snackbär-Sketch. Ja genau, generell unterstüt unterstützt man ihn, wo ihr könnt. Er hat wirklich auch genau gecheckt, was Humor darf und macht immer alles mit. Und ich finde das total geil. Ulf Snarkowski, glaube ich. Ulf Snarkowski im Bärenkostüm. Ja, und auch im Tannenhaus generell mega, also wenn ihr irgendwie die Chance habt, das mal zu gucken, online oder sowas, guckt euch das an. Tolle Inszenierung, super lustig. Kann man dich sehen? Kann man dich sehen im Publikum? Man kann mich, glaube ich, nicht sehen. Hast du die Hände hochgerissen bei irgendwelchen Momenten? Na da, ein paar Mal. Jetzt habe ich reingerufen. Money! Snackbear! Der Snackbear! Den Kelly vom Neo Magazin Royale! Ja, das ist eine andere. Nee, und wirklich, guck dich das an, weil das war auch so eine Performance,
wo danach die Journalisten das für Le Ton geurteilt hat, da darf auch gelacht werden, wo ich auch gerade überdacht denken musste. Warum muss man es immer so betonen? Das ist auch so, das ist so sehr deutsch halt einfach, dieses da darf gelacht werden. Ja, man darf auch in anderen Inszenierungen wahrscheinlich lachen, die nicht so lustig gemeint sind, aber es ist doch generell eine gute, warum soll man das nicht dürfen?
Ja, das ist schwierig, ich bin nicht so bekannt in diesen Wagner-Kreisen, aber welche Leute trifft man da? Also ist man da wirklich mit so den richtig hohen Tieren unterwegs, sitzt du dann in der Loge so mit Walter Vw und Herbert Miele und sowas? Jetzt heute Abend wird das nochmal gespielt und heute Abend ist Frava Steinmeierier da, unser Bundespräsident, Frank Walter Steinmeier, ist heute Abend zu Gast und guckt zu und neben solchen Leuten ist man dann da. Und das Geile ist ja, du hast ja, also die Logen sind eher scheiße, weil die nicht so eine richtig coole Akustik haben und unten da das Parkett, das hat die richtige Bayreuther Akustik, das UNESCO Weltkulturerbe Akustik, wo niemand genau weiß, woran das liegt. Deswegen darf auch nichts verändert werden, weil die nicht wissen, was jetzt die Akustik dann zum Negativen beeinflussen könnte. Deswegen gibt es auch keine Sitzpolster und so, weil die Angst haben, dass es alles kaputt macht. Dass die ganze Musik eingesaugt wird. Dass die eingesaugt wird. Ja, tatsächlich. Da über Jahrtausende die Musikrichtlinien sammeln und die muss man wieder so rausschütteln. Ja, dann muss man die rausschütteln und jetzt ist einfach alles weg. Das kann man nicht.
Und das Coole daran ist, dass dann
glaube ich auch einfach diese Leute auch am Parkett
sitzen, neben einem einfach dann so.
Weil das ist so eine sehr, würde man von Wacklein
ja gar nicht denken, aber eine sehr bodenständige
Geschichte, das ist alles ein
sehr bodenständiges Haus. Das sieht auch
gar nicht aus wie so ein prunkvolles Opernhaus, wie man das so kennt,
sondern das bürgerlichste,
schlichteste Opernhaus, weil er halt so etwas fürs Volk machen wollte. Aber jetzt ist leider so gekommen, dass die Karten nur bezahlbar sind und nur Deutschlands Finanzelite da am Start ist. Aber ja, wobei die Karten waren jetzt auch, ich habe also jetzt auch Karten gesehen, so für 100 Euro oder sowas. Also das ist schon immer noch Steuer, aber halt auch bezahlbar, also geht hin, wenn ihr Bock habt.
Ergibt das Sinn dieses Wagner-Universe? Also ist es vergleichbar mit heutigen Marvel Cinematics, also gibt es da gute Crossover, gute Cameos, gibt es da weitere Teile, Comics?
Generell bin ich ja immer wieder beeindruckt, was viele nämlich nicht wissen ist, das war das erste Theater, das Bayreuther Festspielhaus, wo das Licht im Publikum ausgemacht wurde, weil früher war es einfach gleißend hell im Publikum, weil es gab ja auch schlicht einfach keinen Strom und man hat dann häufig einfach auch damals so Fackeln gehabt und sowas oder was auch immer, also jedenfalls wurde, war der Zuschauerraum beleuchtet und er hat irgendwann gesagt, nee, das machen wir nicht, wir machen die aus, damit alle die Klappe halten, weil es war auch einigermaßen gängig, dass man geredet hat im Publikum. Was ja auch klar ist, wenn das Publikum genauso hell ist wie das andere, dann ist ja alles irgendwie eher so ein Event, wo man mal abends hingeht und lässt sich berieseln, aber es ist auch so, wie man vorm Fernseher sitzt und redet auch manchmal miteinander. Und er hat dann, Richard Wagner war derjenige, der gesagt hat, nee, wir machen das aus. Er war auch der Erste, der gesagt hat, wir verstecken das Orchester unten im Boden, wie es heute im Broadway zum Beispiel auch ja gängig ist, damit sich alle auf das Publikum, auf das Stück konzentrieren können. Und er hat auch dann, es wurde alles nach seinen Entwürfen gebaut, es war quasi wie so eine Fernsehröhre, wie so eine Kinoleinwand. Also es war nicht mehr so offen, sondern er hat abgeschnitten, den Rand so ein bisschen. Und dadurch, also viele sagen, es war auch immer so ein cooler Artikel im New Yorker, dass er quasi auch das Kino mit erfunden hat. Weil du sitzt da, es ist wie ein Kino, hast kein Orchester, nichts, also es ist einfach, du guckst wie ein Film. Und ja, deswegen hat er zum einen, ist er sehr vergleichbar mit dem Marvel Cinematic Universe und zum anderen, ja, alle Oper machen grob Sinn und sind in einer Welt geschrieben. Lohengrin wird Parsifal erwähnt, schon, war die letzte Oper. Ach nice, okay, kommen die noch mal kurz vor, so was wurde eigentlich aus und dann so, ah, der hat jetzt hier einen Krebsstand am Rand und so, ne, finde ich gut. Ich meine, wir sind ja immer auf der Suche, die Super-Elten haben sich jetzt langsam auserzählt,
was ist das nächste große Cinematic Universe.
Ich freue mich auf eine Rückkehr des Bärenmarke-Bärs.
Der ist für mich völlig untergegangen.
Wo ist der?
Ich glaube, es gibt diese Bärenmarkenschnitten nicht mehr.
Der hatte viele gute Figuren auch in seinem Cinematic Universe.
Vielleicht kommt der noch mal ran. Kann Manni ja auch spielen.
Ja, zum Beispiel.
So, der hat schon Bärenerfahrung. Ich habe mir auch gesagt, eigentlich müssten wir so ein Reklam-Cinematic Universe, vielleicht kommt der noch mal ran. Kann Manni ja auch spielen. Ja, zum Beispiel, der hat schon Bärenerfahrung.
Ich habe mir auch gesagt, eigentlich müssten wir so ein Reklam-Cinematic Universe, wünschen wir uns ja.
Mit den grossen Reklam-Helden.
Ja, wo dann noch so Bahnwärter, wie heisst der, Bahnwärter Thiel oder irgendwie sowas, solche Leute.
Die ganzen Leute.
Oder eigentlich wäre so gut so eine Art Super Smash Brothers Spiel, nur halt so für Akademiker einfach,
wo dann irgendwie Effie Priest tritt an gegen Parzival oder irgendwie sowas. Das fände ich auch nicht schlecht. Oh, finde ich auch nicht schlecht. Aber jedenfalls, es war total cool, ich war vor zwei Jahren ja schon mal da und da war es sehr einsam, da bin ich alleine hingefahren, weil ich auch niemanden gefunden hatte, der Bock hatte auf Wagner-Festspiele, bin ich ganz ehrlich. bin dann hingefahren und stand dann halt da einmal in den Pausen rum, ein ein bisschen verloren und dieses Mal halt war ich zum einen natürlich mit einem Kumpel da und aber auch dann mit Manni, der einen dann wirklich so in die Hand genommen hat und wir sind da rüber gelaufen über den grünen elitären Hügel. Und das Geile ist ja bei Manni, alle erkennen ihn ja. Also zum einen aus dem Stück, zum anderen durch seine Körpergröße ist natürlich super leicht erkennbar und so und egal wo er hingeht, er hat keine Chance, dass immer alle auf ihn zukommen und sich freuen, dass er da ist. Und dann sind wir am ersten Tag angekommen, haben ihn getroffen, haben die Karte von ihm bekommen, haben uns dann irgendwie auf ein Bier in der Innenstadt getroffen. Wir waren schon gut drauf, sind dann auf den grünen Hügel gekommen, wo dann alle auf ihn zugelaufen sind und ihm alle irgendwas geschenkt haben. weil wir sind dann durch diese Snackmeile gegangen, die es jetzt so Corona bedingt dann gab, wo er von allen ihm ein Bier ausgegeben hat, bekommen hat und dann hat sich so random, wurde ihm dann so ein Riesenbrot geschenkt von so einem Bäcker, der da war, was er mir dann gegeben hat, was dann dazu führte, dass man leicht angetrunken mit riesigen Broten über diesen Festspielhügel lief. Und dann habe ich die liebe Karen getroffen, ein Fan von uns, eine liebe Podcast-Ufo-Hörerin, die seine Ankleiderin ist, nämlich in dem Stück, weil die ganzen Solisten, die machte Garderobe für die ganzen Solisten bei den Bayreuther Festspielen. Und die hat mich dann noch abends eingeladen, mit den blauen Mädels Bohle zu trinken.
Und ich hatte viele Fragen, als sie das gesagt hat. Ich habe es natürlich sofort zugesagt, weil es klang interessant. Wenn man die Chance hat, die blauen Mädels zu bleiben. Mit den blauen Mädels. Sofort. Stellt sich heraus, die blauen Mädels sind einfach nur der Begriff für alle Einlass, Damen und Frauen, die den Einlass machen, die die Türen ausschließen. Also hat nichts mit der Blumen Group zu tun. Gar nichts mit der Blumen Group. Alles klar. Viel weniger, als ich dachte, mit der Blumen Group zu tun. Und da hat sich seit Jahrzehnten die Tradition entwickelt, weil die den Meistersingern nichts zu tun haben, ungefähr zwei Stunden lang, betrinken die sich hinter den Kulissen mit Bohle.
Ah, okay. Und haben das dann zur Tradition gemacht, dass sie das dann danach fortsetzen.
Und dann habe ich mich plötzlich ein bisschen so studentisch gefühlt.
Also vor zwei Jahren, als ich da alleine war, war es halt so elitär und dann gehen alle auf ihr Hotelzimmer nach. Und jetzt war es plötzlich so, nee, du kannst doch mit den blauen Mädels trinken. Ich dachte mir so, wie cool. Aber dann wurde auch wieder ein bisschen Tradition und Kultur zurückgeholt, denn dann haben sie mir den Standort geschickt, wo sie sich treffen. Ja, wir treffen uns an der Franz-List-Büste. Ah, okay.
Das heißt, das hat mich ein bisschen gefreut,
das sind halt auch noch, also Bayreuth Kicks in,
ein bisschen zumindest noch. Also man trifft
sich da nicht irgendwo im Park, sondern
man trifft sich dann an der Franz-List-Büste.
Sehr schön. Da war dann der Treffpunkt
und dann waren sehr viele blaue Jungs
und blaue Mädels, mit denen man da
schön abbracht hat und viel erfahren hat in den Kulissen.
Ist, glaube ich, der beste Ort, um sich zu treffen, auch für Duelle
oder sowas. Wir treffen uns um 13 Uhr
an der Franz Liszt.
Dann zeige ich dir mal, wer hier
den Haken hängen hat.
Dinge, die man sagt. Wir waren noch nie im Kampf.
Ich habe noch nie gekämpft,
tatsächlich noch nie eine Schlägerei.
Ich habe einmal, das nächste,
woran ich an der Schlägerei war,
war, dass irgendwann der coolste Typ der Klasse erfahren hat, dass ich Karate-Training mache. Und er hat gesagt, ja, schlag mich mal. Und ich so, nein, das verstößt gegen den Karate-Kodex. Nee, du hast gesagt, I couldn't possibly. Und er hat gesagt, nee, doch, mach mal, schlag mich mal in den Bauch. Und dann habe ich tatsächlich einen Kamehameha-artigen Technik ausgepackt und er hat gesagt, ja, nicht schlecht. Das war's, das war's. Du hast ihn doll geschlagen und er hat gesagt, ja, nicht schlecht. Ja, so das war die Situation. Er hat gewonnen. Er hat auf ganze Linie gewonnen und alle Mädchen haben gekichert. Und das war es auch für mich kampfsporttechnisch. Das heißt, eigentlich habe ich da den Karate-Kodex gebrochen, weil mein Karatelehrer das Erste, was er gesagt hat, ist, wir lernen Karate, um es niemals anzuwenden. Im Prinzip Yoda. Das war schon mal eine Ansage, einfach zu sagen, wo ich natürlich als pragmatisch orientierter Mensch sagte, dann gehe ich, dann spiele ich Mario DS. Hinten raschelt es so und man hört so eine Tasche und einen Flüssel und du gehst langsam raus. Und er so, er will. Ach so, nee, ist da nicht so. Nee, ich will es ja nicht anwenden. Lauf weg. Er hat auch gesagt, was mache ich denn, wenn mich jemand bedroht auf der Strasse? Ja, lauf weg. Lauf einfach weg. Ist, glaube ich, auch das Beste, was man machen kann, einfach weglaufen. Ich glaube nicht. Meinst du nicht? Ich glaube, ich bin nicht so schnell. Ah, ich weiß nicht. Aber ich bin lange nicht mehr gerannt, so aus Vollster, weil, ehrlich gesagt, Bundesjugendspiele damals, weiß ich noch, im Jahnstadion, da habe ich noch richtig, ich bin ja richtig gerannt. Da habe ich versucht, so schnell zu rennen, wie es geht. Seitdem habe ich nie mehr versucht, so schnell zu rennen, wie ich kann. Ja, das macht man sehr selten. Und ich bin auch bei den Bundesjugendspielen nicht so schnell gerannt, wie ich konnte, weil ich habe die Strecke auch falsch verstanden. Irgendwie, das war dann so. Du hast, man muss um die Hürden rumlaufen. Nee, weil wir sind alle losgerannt und dann bei der... So, Entschuldigung für diesen kurzen, unangebrachten Soundeffekt gerade. Wir hatten gerade massive technische Probleme. Hier ist ein Blitz eingeschlagen, mitten im Studio. Ja. Schlägt ein Blitz direkt in den Laptop ein. Das ist ungewöhnlich, aber kommt vor manchmal. Das ist ungewöhnlich, wir haben es gegoogelt und selbst dafür gab es eine einfache Lösung und die konnten wir jetzt klären. Die kommen durch die Klimaanlage rein, einfach die schlängeln sich, der Blitz schlängelt sich durch die Klimaanlage und zack trifft das Schwächste Glied. Was ich gehört habe damals, was mich mein Leben lang verunsichert hat, war Kugelblitze. Ja. Weil mein Vater hat mir irgendwann von der Existenz von Kugelblitzen erzählt, die in Räume reinkommen, gefühlt. Die nicht mal anklopfen, die nicht mal anklopfen, die reinplatzen, dich erwischen bei was auch immer du gerade machst und dich vorwurfsvoll anschauen, vorwurfsvoll anschauen, ehe sich dann umbringen einfach. Und da habe ich aber danach auch nicht mehr viel von gehört, was so ein bisschen so, ich dachte, das wäre ein grösseres Problem, als es sich dann rausstellte zu sein.
Ich glaube, das war ein Phänomen in den 80ern, dass es die halt wahnsinnig viel gab, als auch irgendwie die Amerikaner mit Tesla-Spulen experimentiert haben, Blitzattacken, Blitzangriffe bei Pikachu und so, da kam das ja alles her ursprünglich, das kam ja alles aus der amerikanischen Forschung. Die haben ja tatsächlich versucht, Elektromäuse zu züchten. Ja. Also haben versucht, Mäusen die Fäh zu geben, Elektro-Blitze zu schießen. Das wurde dann alles aufgefangen,
japanische Spione und so entstand dann
Pikachu, um das zu veröffentlichen
an die Welt, sozusagen, ohne dass
sie preisgeben mussten, dass sie Spione hatten und so weiter.
Ich glaube, da gab es einen Elektro-Hype.
Das ist eine super langweilige Geschichte.
Deswegen, glaube ich, gab es
diesen Elektro-Hype, wo dann plötzlich
auch Blitze in aller Munde waren,
sprichwörtlich, wortwörtlich direkt. Und deswegen war das ein Thema, das heute untergeht. Ja, das geht unter, ja wie gesagt, das sind wahnsinnig zähe, langweilige Geschichten. Alles, was mit Blitzen zu tun hat, ist langweilig und zäh. Alles, was mit Pikachu-Blitzen und Spionage zu tun hat, ist unglaublich zäh und langwierig. Nee, aber deswegen dachte ich, es wäre ein großes Problem. Bislang keine Erfahrung mit Kugelblitzen gemacht. Höchstens eher mal mit richtigen Blitzen, aber auch die waren nie, es war nie gefährlich. Dieses Ganze, man stellt sich nicht unter Bäume und nicht rausgehen bei Gewitter und so, ist doch auch ein bisschen Humbug, oder? Ja, ich finde es vor allem halt schwierig, dass Leute überleben, die ja vom Blitz getroffen werden, weil ich denke, die Wahrscheinlichkeit, überhaupt getroffen zu werden, ist so extrem gering.
Und dann überlebt man auch noch.
Also dann das Schlimmste, was passieren kann, ist, dass du so ein cooles Blitz-Tattoo auf dem Rücken hast. Ich will das jetzt gar nicht verharmlosen, aber es ist cool. Ich glaube auch nicht, dass es so ein Blitz-Tattoo, so ein Harry Potter-eskes Mal kommt. Nein, aber ich sage ja nur, es ist nicht die schlechteste Geschichte. Du hast halt sofort auf Tinder eine gute erste Line. Ich wurde mal für einen Blitz getroffen, als ich dein Bild gesehen habe. Und? Und 2009. Was man bei Tinder manchmal liest, dieses drei Sätze über mich, zwei Fakten, eine Lüge. Und dann ist er bei, ich wurde für einen Blitz getroffen. Ja, genau. Ich war schon mal in Madagaskar, ich habe einen sehr großen Penis und ich wurde für einen Blitz getroffen. Du warst noch nie in Madagaskar, richtig. Ja, sowas, das ist gar nicht schlecht. Das kann man dann halt machen, aber das ist so ein Ding, ich meine, wir alle wissen, okay, fuck, wir haben Roadrunner gesehen, Armbosse fallen vom Himmel, Klaviere fallen vom Himmel, alles. Nee, eigentlich nur die beiden. Genau, die beiden, und davor habe ich Angst, weil da wirst du nicht überleben, aber einen Blitz ... Ach, weiß ich nicht. Nee, genau, auch das, lernen von amerikan, aber hier sind wir wieder bei den Amerikanern, die uns weismachen wollen, Blitze sind nicht so gefährlich, wie sie vielleicht einfach sind, weil in den ganzen amerikanischen Cartoons kennt jeder dieses Skelett, was man dann kurz sieht, eine Comicfigur wird vom Blitz getroffen, hell, gleißend helles Licht, nach außen hin, in der Mitte das Skelett zu sehen und danach ist meistens alles gut. Vielleicht raucht man noch ein bisschen. Ja, genau und dann halt so die Haare stehen zu Berge und all das. Das einzige Moment, wo man Berge sagt, ist einfach stehen zu Berge immer. Aber das ist auch das einzige, aber Strom ist auch, also ich will gar nichts so tun, als hätte ich Strom verstanden, irgendwie gar nicht auch so. Ich war am Wochenende unterwegs unter einer Plane, ich war lange unter einer Plane und dann war die Plane irgendwann statisch geladen und alle Haare stehen zu Berge, zu Plane in dem Fall. Bist du denn zu Plane, bist du mit dem Auto zu Plane gefahren oder bist du mit dem Zug zu Plane? Nein, da wurde mit dem Auto. Zug stehe mir vor so einem Güterzug, wie du unter so einer Plane hängst. Nee, ich bin so auf einem schon fahrenden Zug ganz lange nebenher gerannt, hab dann mein Gepäck reingeworfen und hab es dann noch geschafft, gerade reinzukommen, um zur Plane zu kommen, bin dann da ausgestiegen. Und mit zu Berge stehen den Hagen zu Plane aus. Richtig, und an der Plane und dann auch da keine Ahnung, was da ist, keine Ahnung, was da passiert, was da los ist, warum jetzt diese Plane zu
Berge und das ist alles völlig konfus.
Ich war ja in
Italien, bin dann mit dem Auto
hingefahren. Du warst in Italien. Ja, ja, wie gesagt,
hatten wir ja schon das Thema, aber
Stefano in Italien.
Arrivederci.
Und da war ich mit
Schweizern und ich bin dann zusammen gemeinsam über den Gotthardpass gefahren, wo uns auch ein Zug entgegenkam, ein Dampflok. Und für mich war das das grösste Ereignis. Ich bin gefahren, das heißt, ich konnte jetzt nicht immer so lange hingucken, wie ich wollte. Es fielen Sätze wie, kannst du mal das Lenkrad halten, ich würde gerne diese Bahnlänge angucken, wurden alle abgeschmettert, je nach, aber auch, weil die Deutschen nicht verstanden haben, aber gut, jedenfalls dann habe ich dann diesen Zug angeschaut und dachte mir, Wahnsinn, aber die Schweizer waren nicht so beeindruckt davon, weil die das, glaube ich, häufiger sehen. Das war generell den ganzen Trip so, weil ich als jemand aus Köln und dem Rheinland, dem flachen Rheinland, bin jetzt ja nicht Berge gewohnt, aber überall Berge. Wahnsinn. Und die sind ja richtig hoch und dann auch schön und dann fallen da Bäche runter, so Sturzbäche, Sturzbäche zu Berge fallen runter und diese Wälder und das ist ja einfach unfassbar schöne Natur, die ich so nicht kenne. Du kennst dich auch, du bist ja in der Nähe von München. Ja, ich glaube, es ist ein ganz einfaches System, weil Berge machen eine Landschaft einfach mehr. 3D.
Du siehst, in der dreidimensionalität. Es muss mehr rendern. Wenn du sonst einfach flach bist, dann siehst du Himmel und Boden, aber so, das macht es einfach, da ist mehr los. Es ist wie so eine Kulisse. Berge sind eigentlich eine Art Weltkulisse. Bühnenende. Genau, wo einfach mehr zu sehen ist, wo du einfach eine Dreidimensionalität hast. Setz halt auch Dinge in Perspektive, weil jeder von uns weiß, wie ein Baum, wie gross ein Baum ist, so ein Durchschnittsbaum, wenn du aber flaches Land hast und du siehst hinten so eine Baumgipfel, weißt du ja nicht, wie gross ist denn der Baum, wohingegen wenn du so einen Berg siehst, einen riesen Berg und da siehst du ja fast den ganzen Baum oben auf dem Gipfel noch stehen, dann hast du ja erstmal eine Perspektive, das heißt, weißt du, du hast immer so einen Maßstab, hier Banana for Scale mässig, hast du dann bei so einem Berg, du weißt immer, was los ist, ja.
Genau, so eine Eiche for Scale vom Gotthard. Und wenn jemand auf dich zukommt, weißt du, ah, der ist so und so groß, weil du hast den Gotthard im Hintergrund, du weißt genau, was los ist. Ja. Aber es ist auch so, ich bin da unsicher, weil ich meine, wir sind ja Ästheten und wir lieben das Schöne in der Welt, aber es gibt natürlich verschiedene Erklärungsansätze, warum wir Dinge schön finden, die wir schön finden. Also kann man natürlich evolutionär versuchen zu erklären, die ganzen Sachen. Und ich habe letztens gehört, weil ein beliebtes Motiv für Maler sind ja immer Landschaften, die malen ja ständig Landschaften. Und ich habe gehört, warum Menschen so gerne Landschaften anschauen, ist, weil man da einfach einen guten Überblick hat.
Und da sieht man denselben Zahntiger schon lange heranrasen. Und deswegen mag man es, grosse offene Flächen anzuschauen, weil der Mensch da einfach darauf gepolt ist, das gut zu finden. Auch das kennt man ja aus Filmen, aus Horrorfilmen, ah Gott sei Dank eine Lichtung. Ja, endlich die Lichtung. Endlich eine Lichtung. Endlich die Lichtung. Das hört man so oft. Oh, hier ist eine Lichtung. Endlich die Lichtung. Aber auch bei in Büchern immer so. Und dann Stiessen Sie auf eine Lichtung. Das hört man so oft. Hier ist eine Lichtung. Endlich die Lichtung. Aber auch bei Büchern immer so. Und dann stiessen sie auf eine Lichtung. Ja, ist immer gut. Es ist ein klotz der Durchschnaufung. Es ist ein Plateau, wo du kurz mal Überblick hast und entspannen kannst. Wo ich mir mal dachte, da ist für mich plötzlich Jahrhunderte Kunstgeschichte in Bach runtergeflossen. Weil ich mir dachte, das ist der Grund, einfach weil man den Säbelzahntiger gut sehen kann. deswegen schaut man sich Landschaften an, all diese tollen Künstler spielen eigentlich nur mit unseren ureigensten Instinkten, mich hat das enttäuscht, mich hat das sehr enttäuscht, ist vielleicht auch Quatsch, weil im Grunde kannst du ja alles evolutionär erklären, weil du kannst sagen, warum mögen Menschen Kaffee, Kannst du sagen, ja, weil die Evolutionär darauf gepolt sind, wach zu bleiben.
Gut, wird nicht falsch sein, weil per Definition kann nichts, was wir sind, nicht per Definition, per Evolution erklärt werden. Von daher, es ist so, es ist ein bisschen langweilig, aber man hat mich desillusioniert. Ja, mich jetzt auch da desillusioniert, weil es ist halt, ich finde, Begeisterung zu empfinden, für zum Beispiel diese Dampflok, wird auch dann genähert, wenn es halt auf, wenn die Begeisterung auch im Auto auf fruchtbaren Boden stößt. Wenn da aber drei Leute sitzen, von denen einer pennt und zwei sagen, die fährt hier immer lang, ist es halt nicht mehr, man empfindet es nicht mehr so doll. Das heißt, ich bin ein sehr begeisterungsfähiger Mensch und das finde ich, ich mag viele Eigenschaften an mir nicht, das mag ich wiederum. Und ich finde, das wird auch bei allen immer gesagt, ich selber nehme es bei anderen Menschen als positive Eigenschaft wahr, seid begeisterungsfähig. Begeisterungsfähigkeit ist das Beste, ich glaube, deswegen wollen Leute auch Kinder, weil Kinder haben noch diese Magie in den Augen oder auch Hunde oder so, irgendwie, wenn du so ein Video siehst von einem Hund, wo jemand so die Decke hochnimmt und danach weg ist und der Hund so what the fuck, was war das denn und alle so ja geil. Hunde sind so Hype Men in Women, die sind einfach hyped, immer am Start, außer bei Blaubeeren. Ja, Blaubeeren hassen sie einfach, wirklich, da gibt es ein, habe ich auch letztes Video gesehen, also ich check Hunde mittlerweile nicht mehr, ich weiß nicht, was fake ist und was echt. Da meinte er so, ja, der Moment, wenn der Hund versteht, dass wir seinen Lieblingsfilm angemacht haben. Und da kam halt dann so dieses Pixar-Intro und da gibt es ja immer so diese Logos von den verschiedenen Studios und was weiß ich, Dreamworks und verschiedene. Und dann irgendwann kommt der Moment, wo der Film individuell wird, wo der Film, man merkt, ah, das ist dieser Pixar-Film. Und der Hund war schon aufgeregt die ganze Zeit während den Logos und als er dann gesehen hat, ah, es ist ab, dann hat er sich richtig gefreut. Wo ich mir dachte, vergiss es, damit das funktioniert, muss so viel, also erst mal muss der Hund überhaupt checken, was ein Film ist, der Hund muss checken, dass es mehrere Filme gibt. Der Hund muss verstehen, dass mehrere Filme denselben Anfang haben, aber ab einem gewissen Punkt individuell werden. Aber guck mal, so eine Familie, bei der er wohnt, die werden wahrscheinlich ja, sagen wir mal, jeden dritten, vierten Abend einen Film gucken. Vielleicht sogar jeden. Bei einer Sieben-Tage-Woche dann, nee. Jeden dritten Tag. Deswegen hast du gesagt, dritter, vierter, damit du sagst, immer mittwochs oder was? Immer mittwochs und sonntags. Nee, ich bin jetzt eher generell einfach numerisch durchgegangen. Nee, das kannst du nicht machen, wenn du sagst bei einer sieben Tage Woche, wenn du jeden dritten Tag einen Film guckst. Das gibt manche Samstage, das gibt man. Ja, du guckst ja jeden Wochentag dann ein, das geht nicht. Du musst Teilhand durch sieben nehmen. Nee, ich dachte eher so, jeder dritte im Sinne von, man geht jetzt nicht von Wochentagen aus, sondern wenn man alle Wochentage übereinander schreibt und dann alle Samstagen kriegen Strich, dann hat man ja trotzdem so statistisch an jedem dritten Tag einen Film geschaut. Also jeder Dienstag und jeder Samstag, sagen wir mal. Also durchschnittlich jeder dritte Tag. Genau, sowas war gemeint. Ja, und da wird er viele Filme in seinem Leben mitbekommen
haben und wahrscheinlich,
ich kann mir das schon vorstellen,
er muss ja nicht wissen, dass es ein Film ist.
Er muss nur wissen,
ah, das ist eine Situation,
die ich jetzt durchmachen werde, die mir
Spaß macht. Nämlich immer diese
und hier sind wir ja gar nicht so weit weg von
LogTV und diesen lustigen tanzenden
Erdbeeren mit den lustigen Gesichtern, die haben einen Ballonkopf, die haben einen Ballonkörper. So, und wenn Up ist sein Lieblingsfilm mit den lustigen Ballons. Das kann schon sein, ja. Trotzdem, ich bin da immer sehr, sehr skeptisch, was das angeht, weil der muss ja eigentlich das Hollywood-Studiosystem verstehen, um zu checken, was da passiert, was da vor sich geht. Ich verstehe das, wenn der Film, wenn überhaupt der Fernseher angeht, dass er sich dann freut, dass er vercheckt, was da los ist. Aber dass Tiere zwischen verschiedenen Filmen unterscheiden können, glaube ich nicht, bis ich sehe. Es ist alles immer gut gestaged. Nee, weil... Keine Ahnung, da sitzt halt jemand und zwickt ihm dann in den Rücken oder was und dann ha ha. Nee, ich glaube... Und dann schreit er auf Schmerz. Weil es so toll ist. Und der dumme Zuschauer interpretiert das als, ah, der hat verstanden, dass jetzt sein Film losgeht. Bullshit. Ich glaube das nicht. Wie weit kann man das treiben? Der Moment, wenn dein Lieblingsrochen merkt, dass ein guter Film, also wie lange, der Moment, wenn Quallen die Star Wars Melodie hören, also wann, wie weit kann man dieser Moment, wenn Tiervideos treiben, bis man irgendwann sagt, so ja, das ist jetzt Bullshit. Der Moment, wenn Korallen feststellen, dass Beethovens neunte läuft, so, das ist doch. Ja, genau, also Beethovens erste bis siebte, völlig uninteressant. Einfach dieses typische Rumgewaber der Korallen. Aber acht und neun sind einfach links, rechts, links, rechts. Und alles wird noch mal mehr in die Höhe gestreckt und die ganze Korallen von links nach rechts. Ich verfolge jetzt auch, das Problem ist, TikTok oder generell diese Kurzvideo-Algorithmen, die checken ja immer, was du anschaust und geben dir mehr, auch wenn du es nicht gerne anschaust. Auch wenn du es anschaust und dich polternd darüber aufregst. Das weiss der nicht. Der hat ja ein seltenes Mikrofon an, der sagt einfach mehr davon. Und der spielt jetzt ganz viele Videos in den Timeline von Hunden, die auf Knöpfe drücken. Es gibt so Leute, manche Leute, die haben Hunde und die erziehen die so, dass sie auf Knöpfe drücken, die dann Soundeffekt abspielen und damit können die kommunizieren. Und richtig gut fand ich den einen Hund, der hat dann wirklich wie so eine ganze Klavier vor sich mit ganz vielen Buzzern und dann drückt er auf einen Buzzer, der beschrieben ist mit Treat, Treat, Treat, Treat, Treat, Treat, Treat, Treat, Treat. Und er hat so oft auf diesen Buzzer draufgedrückt, dass der Buzzer irgendwann aus der Halterung rausgeploppt ist und daneben lag und dann eher ganz unsicher Help, Help, Help, Help, Help, help. Und das fand ich einerseits so lustig, dass er gesagt hat, ich brauche Hilfe, um meinen Treat-Button bitte wieder zu aktivieren. Help, help, help. Aber er dachte mir auch, nein, die trainieren immer halt an auf die zwei Knöpfe. Ich weiß es nicht, ich unterschätze vielleicht Hunde, vielleicht sind Hunde super schlau, aber ich glaube einfach nicht daran, dass sie einen eigenen Willen haben, weil das würde einfach zu viele Dinge rückwirkend in meinem Leben zu sehr furchtbaren Aktionen machen.
Und ich habe viele Hunde beschimpft und ganz fies angeguckt und deswegen glaub nicht dran.
Ich habe ja auch mal gehört, dass man sozusagen so ein Alpha ausstrahlt, der Alpha zu sein, wenn man den lange in die Augen guckt und das Blickduell gegen Hunde gewinnt. Also wer zuerst wegschaut, verliert. Und seitdem mache ich das bei Hunden immer, weil ich mir das nicht die Bösse geben will, gegen so einen Chihuahua zu verlieren. Und deswegen gucke ich die immer lange an. Und manchmal ist es unangenehm lang. Und auch wenn ich da von der Seite angesprochen werde und so, Stefan, wir müssen jetzt weitergehen, bin ich halt noch in diesem Blickduell gefangen. Ja. Weil ich seitdem, ich will mir diese Blödsinn nicht geben. Aber warum nicht? Warum ist dir das wichtig, über den Hund zu stehen? Weil er demjenigen Hund, der die Gegend gehört. Und was muss ich dann machen? Ach so, du meinst, dass du dann irgendwann dich ihm unterordnest und dann ihm Befehle folgen musst? Nee, das ist ja der Moment. Genau, er ist dann federführend. Und ich bin untergeordnet. Er ist federführend. Okay, gut. Und du musst der Feder folgen, du bist federuntergeordnet. Er ist federführend und wer schreibt, der bleibt. Also dann, wo bleibe ich denn dann? Was legt das Pling zu? Das sind halt die Regeln der Tierwelt. Das sind die Regeln der Natur. Das ist das Problem. Ja, da kommst du ja auch nicht mehr raus. Da kommt man nicht raus. Ja, das stimmt schon. Ich verliere keinen Blick, du ehrlich. Aber ganz merkwürdig, dass es Hierarchien zwischen verschiedenen Spezies geben kann, oder? Also ich kann verstehen, dass ein Hund einen anderen Hund anbellt, aber wenn du jetzt so einen Pinguin hast oder so und so ein Pinguin und so ein Hund machen ein Duell, der sagen, ja, du bist, wir haben ja andere Regierungssysteme, Königspinguine, vor allem sind ja Leben in der Monarchie, Hunde ja in so einer Stammes, der Stammes-, der Stärkere gewinnt, Stammeskultur. In so einem Nomaden, Nomadenrudelgeharbe. Ja, was Nomadisches, was Parasitäres natürlich auch. Sie gehen in die Menschenwelt. Was Paralitäres. Richtig, Paramilitärisches. Was Paralitäres. Sie gehen da rein und zecken sich quasi an den Mensch an, der Mensch kontrolliert sie aber auch. Also es ist eine ganz merkwürdige Staatsform. Welche Tiere haben die ähnlichste Staatsform wie wir? Oh, das ist eine gute Frage. Welche Staatsform haben wir überhaupt? Müssen wir jetzt auch mal überlegen. Leben wir noch in der Demokratie? Ja, ja, okay. Ne, ernsthaft, frage ich das nicht mal. Ne, ich möchte aber nicht, dass du deine... Ernsthaft? Ich will dich mal Stellung beziehen, Stefan. Ich spreche das oft an, aber du wieselst dich dann da oft raus. Leben wir noch in der Demokratie, ja oder nein? Ja, ja. Ja, okay, gut.
Okay, dann kann ich dir drei Artikel schicken, weil ich würde da gerne intensiver mit dir drüber reden.
Also, welche Tiere haben ... Wahrscheinlich einen Bienenstock, oder?
Sowas, die wirklich so ein Klassensystem haben.
Gar keinen Fall.
Die haben eine Königin.
Die schlafen nicht.
Die sind wirklich in der Monarchie.
Königspinguine tun nur so.
Ja, stimmt schon. Die gemeinsame Entscheidungen treffen, um dann weiterzuziehen. Vielleicht so Termiten oder sowas, weiß ich nicht. Oder gibt es einen Termitenkönig. Das kann schon sein. Oder so Fledermäuse oder so Schwaben. Oder Gänse oder sowas. So Gänse, die unterwegs sind und dann, die sich so zusammenschliessen und die ja dann nur so schnell fliegen wie der Langsamste. Die sich zusammenschliessen, wie zu einem grossen Schwan?, zu so einem grossen Flugzeug-Sort, so einem Megasort. Einfach wie so ein grosser Schwan. Das finde ich geil. Das ist ja auch das Ding mit so diesen Sardellenschwärmen, wo ich mir denke, formieren die sich manchmal so, dass sie aussehen wie eine grössere Sardelle? Eine riesige Sardelle. Also dass sie verstehen, wie sie selbst aussehen und das dann imitieren. Aber ich glaube nicht, die haben sich für den Ball entschieden oder einfach für irgendwelche Schwarmmuster, aber dass die mal wirklich so einen Donut darstellen oder sowas. Die könnten ja völlig eine ganz neue Intelligenz erreichen. Wenn die viel enger zusammenschwimmen, also weil alles sieht ja noch nach Schwarm aus, wenn die aber eher enger zusammenrutschen würden, dann könnte es ja aussehen wie ein anderer Haifisch zum Beispiel. Ja. Oder wie ein Wal. Und dann würde der Hai vielleicht weggehen. Aber so schwimmt der einfach durch diesen Sardellenschwarm und der Schwarm will überleben, aber dem Individuum ist es egal. Vor allem, du könntest aussehen wie ein Hai, der irgendwie so ein riesiges Schwert im Maul hat oder so. Oder irgendwas noch cooleres als ein Hai. Oder eine Augenklappe. Ja, oder eine Augenklappe. Du kannst ja alles draus machen. Oder eine Leiter oder so. Und dass der halt eine Leiter auf dem Rücken hat. Oder irgendwie sowas in der Richtung. Das wäre ein richtiges Highlight. Nice. Sehr schön. Wo der andere Hai einfach sagt, ho, der hat eine Leiter. Oder sowas Witziges, so ein Hai mit Schwimmflügeln oder sowas. Ja. Das fände ich witzig. Wo der andere Hai auch nicht anders kann als ... Ja, war geil. Bisschen wie die Unterrichtsstunde von Professor Lupin in Star Wars 3. Star Wars 3. In Harry Potter Teil 3. Wo die sich alle in Mücken verwandeln. Nee, wo die sich gegen diesen Gringotts kämpfen. Und genau, die steigen alle aus diesem Spiegel der Wünsche raus und dann müssen die dann irgendwie sagen Patronus und dann... Genau, die lernen auch diesen Patronus und dann aber verstehen lustige Dinge. Genau, aber hat nicht der eine auch den Ring, wo er dann irgendwie unsichtbar werden kann? Ja, genau, aber den wirft er dann wieder in den Spiegel rein, wo er dann schmilzt. Ich habe letztens noch mal... Und dann sagt Gandalf, ich heiße Dumbledore. Aber ich habe letzt noch mal nachgedacht über Herr der Ringe 1. Und du hast ihn ja wahrscheinlich noch im Kopf, diese Szene, wo die Bösen, die Nazgul, die Ringreiter, die Ringgeister nach Bre gehen und dann in diesen Raum reingehen und mit den Schwertern die Betten zerstechen. Was zur Hölle passiert in dieser Szene? Damit das funktioniert, muss Streicher Aragorn mit den Hobbits in dem einen Gasthaus ... Wir gehen durch den ganzen Tag durch. Wie soll das funktionieren? Die Hobbits kommen da an. In Bre. In Bre. Frodo meldet sich als Herr Unterberg und mietet ein Zimmer. Ja, dann treffen sie auf Streicher, der irgendwie versteht, oh, hier sind Nazgul in der Gegend. Also was macht Streicher? Streicher sagt, oh, welches Zimmer habt ihr gebucht auf Unterberg? Ah, Zimmer vier. Ah, dann gehe ich da kurz hoch und stopfe die Betten mit die Bettdecken und präpariert es so, als würden da Leute schlafen. Und dann sagt Pippin, oh, ich bin müde, lass uns das Bett gehen. Nein, nein, wir gehen nicht ins Zimmer vier, wir gehen in anderes Gasthaus. Wir gehen ins Gasthaus zum abgefuckten Pony, das gegenüberliegt. Später in der Nacht kommen die Ringgeister, wahrscheinlich weil sie gecheckt haben, dass irgendjemand den Ring aufgesetzt hat. Frodo setzt den Ring ja kurz auf und deswegen haben die da so eine Art GPS-Ping, da ist was. Ja, aber die haben diesen Ping, der nur auf 100 Meter genau ist, sagen wir mal. Genau, das weiß ich gar nicht, weil die finden ja das richtige Gasthaus, da wo Frodo den Ring aufgesetzt hat. Die müssen aber gefragt haben mit ihrer Nachschool-Stimme. Richtig, die gehen jetzt zum... Wo ist denn Unterberg? Aber die wissen ja nicht Unterberg.
Das heisst, die gehen jetzt zum... Wo ist denn Unterberg? Aber die wissen ja nicht Unterberg. Das heißt, die fragen, Beutlin. Und der Gast wird, na Moment, da machen wir ja so, Beutlin haben wir jetzt nicht. Und dann so, ja, vielleicht. Nein, das ist Wolfgang Fölz, Käpt'n Blaubeer. Das fragt doch. Nein, das haben wir ihn nicht. Naja, wir haben nur ein Zimmer besetzt heute auf Unterberg.
Ja, das kann auch sein.
Dann gehen die in das Zimmer, machen die Tür auf,
gehen über die Betten, zerstechen die,
während Aragon im anderen Gasthaus sitzt, sagt,
haben wir denen jetzt ein Prank?
Ein Prank ist ein Prank.
Ist ein Prank.
Die haben kein Blut an den Schwertern.
Nichts.
Überall fliegen Federn rum. Der Gastvist sagt auch, Leute, habt ihr einen Schaden. Habt ihr einen Schaden, das bezahlt ihr aber jetzt, oder was? Und haltet ihr was aus der Minibar? Nein. Die haben es zerstochen und haben aber dann ihrer Meinung nach die Aufgabe abgeschlossen. Genau, weil der nächste Punkt für die Nazgul wäre, ja, dann lassen es halt mal in den anderen Gasthäusern. Also die beraten sich kurz und setzen sich auf die Betten enttäuscht. Setzen sich enttäuscht auf dem Becken. Und lassen die Schultern hängen und sagen, ach Scheiße. Ich bin mit dem Schwert so im Holzboot, haben die so reingeschickt und drehen dann so, weißt du, diese Dinge, die man macht, wenn man gerade Langeweile hat. Genau, tappen so mit ihren Reiterschuhen auf den Mund. Was machen wir denn jetzt? Ja, also wollen wir vielleicht erst mal, nee, äh. Du hast mir heute gesagt, ich darf auch mal eine Entscheidung treffen. Nein, Gary, hör mal zu kurz. Lass uns mal in die anderen Zimmer von demselben Gasthaus gucken. Nur mal gucken. Aber wir sind die ja nicht mehr. Wir haben gefragt, Frodo Beutlin, Auenland, die haben gesagt, Unterberg, das ist... Solche fucking Wichser, ey, dann machen die auch noch in den Betten da die Bettdecken vor. Wir haben gesagt, wir fluchen nicht mehr. Wir haben gesagt, wir sind die Nahschool, wir sind keine... Ja, okay, aber ich finde es schon ein bisschen frech, dass die uns hierher locken und dann auch noch die Betten präparieren. Ich meine, wir haben uns den Job nicht ausgesucht, wir sind verflucht, okay? Wir wurden geprankt, okay? Wir wurden geprankt. Es hört uns niemand, du kannst normal reden. Wir wurden geprankt. Ja, wir wurden geprankt. Und das ist halt scheiße so, da sind wir uns ja auch alle einig. Aber wir müssen jetzt auch, und ich finde, da hat Gary total recht, dem du auch heute Morgen gesagt hast, dass er mal wieder mehr entscheiden darf, dass wir jetzt mal nach vorne gucken und nicht immer nach hinten gucken. Gut, du guckst immer nur nach hinten. Justus, dann geh du doch mal in Raum drei und Manuel, du ins Raum vier. Nee, ich finde, nein, weil das Gasthaus hier haben wir ja jetzt einmal quasi. Die werden uns doch nicht pranken und dann im selben Gasthaus bleiben. Wir haben doch Wolfgang Földs gefragt, wo wir genau jetzt hier auf Unterberg treffen. Das sind die Beutlins Halblinge, die wir gesucht haben. Währenddessen im anderen Gasthaus. Die hast du gesühlt, wie die da reingestangen haben. Und was machen wir jetzt? Ja, jetzt gehen wir ins Bett, oder? Wir schlafen einfach, oder? Ja, aber die sind doch noch im anderen Gasthaus. Frodo, chill, okay? Du hast dir viel zu viele Gedanken. Die ganze Reise, weißt du, ich bin zum ersten Mal aus dem Auland raus, ich bin Sam, ich bin zum ersten Mal aus dem Auland raus, das weiss ich doch, weißt du, wer du bist. Ja, ich stand. Ich meine, wir mussten die Lichter löschen, damit die uns nicht sehen, aber ich kann dich an der Stimme noch erkennen. Psch, lass mal ein bisschen leider, aber ich meine nur so, ich bin zum ersten Mal raus und du bist die ganze Zeit nur am mäkeln und wir sind am fliehen und jetzt lass mal einfach chillen. Wir sollen jetzt hier schlafen, wo gerade hundert Meter weiter die den Raum auseinandergenommen haben. Lass gute Nacht sagen, aber nach dem Gute-Nacht-Sagen noch ein bisschen reden, ja? Nee, das hasse ich. Lass uns wirklich nach dem Gute-Nacht-Sagen nicht mehr reden, dass man weiß, wann man, weil sonst denke ich die ganze Zeit nach, worüber könnte ich reden. Mary, du rauchst schon wieder Pfeife. Ohne Scheiß, du rauchst zu viel. Pippin, hast du eine Wurst in der Hosentasche? Hast du die gegrillt gerade? Und zurück bei den Ringgeistern. Gut, dann lass uns nach Hause gehen für heute. War ein blöder Tag. Leute, jetzt lasst euch dann aber nicht so hängen, Mensch, bis dann die Ringgeister. Ja, aber dann krieg ich wieder, weil ihr habt mit dem ja nichts zu tun, weil ihr euch immer schön raushaltet. Ich muss wieder sauren sagen. Das stimmt nicht. Nein, das stimmt nicht. W wann hast du das letzte Mal sauren gesagt, dass wir die Aufgabe nicht richtig ausgefüllt haben? Als du krank warst, habe ich alle Briefe geschrieben. Das war einmal vor 53 Jahren. Ja, und? Ja, ich sage nur, ich habe die letzten Jahre immer mit ihm gesprochen. Jetzt muss ich wieder mit ihm telefonieren und ihm vielleicht sagen, dass es nicht geklappt hat. Und dann kann man mit den anderen, was ist mit euch denn los? Ich wünschte neun, ich dachte, ich reichen, hätte ich mir doch die achtzehn gemacht. Was sollen wir denn machen? Wir können nichts sehen, wir können nichts riechen, wir können nichts machen. Wir sind quasi tot. Wir sind nahezu nichts. Das einzige, was wir haben, ist dieser GPS-Ping, wenn jemand seinen Ring aufsetzt. Und diese coolen Rüstungen. Ja, die sind cool. Also wie gesagt, ich würde sagen, wir gehen zu Hause, gehen ins Bett. Wo ist unser Zuhause? Diese grüne Festung. Minas Morgul? Minas Morgul. Wir sollen jetzt noch, Alter, es ist nach zehn, sollen jetzt noch nach Minas Morgul reiten. Okay, wir bleiben hier. Lass uns hier schlafen. Wir schlafen hier. Jetzt haben wir halt alle Betten zerstochen. Was war das denn für eine Aktion, Paul? Ja, wie soll man denn sonst sicher gehen, dass Menschen umgebracht werden? Aber es sind Halblingen, vielleicht hätten wir auch halb so dort auf einschlafen. Wie dem auch sei, wir bleiben jetzt... Es sind halt vier Betten. Lass uns hier schlafen. Ich kann gerne mit Gary in einem Bett schlafen. Gut, dann Gary und du, Anton, du kannst ja auf dem Boden schlafen. Ja. Gut. Also dann bis morgen, lasst euch nicht von den Bettenmaden beißen. Ja, gute Nacht. War ein guter Tag trotzdem. Gute Nacht. Gute Nacht. Hey. Ja. Was denn? Ich finde es mega nervig, dass er die ganze Zeit diese Ansagen macht. Weil ohne Scheiss. Ja. Ja, wie uncool ist das denn. Wir haben keinen Chef. Wir sind alle gleich aus. Alle unsere Rüstungen. Das stimmt nicht, einer ist der Hexenkönig. Aber ich habe vergessen, wer. Ja, ich auch. Bist du? Wir haben, nein. Sagen du, dass du der Hexenkönig bist. Meinst, kann man einfach so sagen? Ja, wir können uns doch nicht aus. Aber guck uns doch mal, wir sind alle gleich aus. Nicht einer von uns hat irgendwie so ein Abzeichen, so Hexenkönig von Mominas Morgul auf dem, wir haben sich auf uns Stirn stehen. Wir sind alle gleich aus, wir sind offensichtlich gleich prächtig. Das geht mir so oft. Ja, aber du kannst es auch nicht vom Aussehen abhängig machen. Hey, könnt ihr wieder auf den Klappen halten? Wir haben eigentlich gesagt, Gute Nacht ist wirklich Ende. Sucht euch ein anderes Zimmer. Ja, okay. Okay. Siehst du, genau das meine ich. Aber ich finde es halt blöd, wenn man sagt, man macht es nach dem Aussehen.
Ich finde, der, der die besten Führungsqualitäten an den Tag legt, der sollte auch der Anführer sein und nicht der jetzt irgendwie dann so eine Kron oder rote Augen oder sowas.
Wer findest du die besten Führungsqualitäten?
Nee, also ich finde, du machst das schon ganz gut.
Nee, eben ganz gut, das ist einfach die Klage halten, weil... Okay, gute Nacht.
Gute Nacht.
Danke, hab dich lieb. Ich dich auch. Ich glaube, genau so lief das ab, weil anders kann ich mir das nicht erklären. Du hast schon recht, dass noch die Szene passiert. Ich meine, klar, trotzdem guter Film, ich will jetzt nicht sagen, gebt die Oscars zurück. Versteht mich nicht falsch. Ich meine, nur diese Szene ergibt von Anfang bis Ende überhaupt keinen Sinn. Aber ich finde ja, Filme haben ja den großen Vorteil, dass man einfach Dinge weglassen kann. Absolut. Und du denkst ja zu häufig über diesen Film nach. Ich habe ihn schon ein paar Mal gesehen und es gibt einfach Stellen, wo ich frage was los.
Man kommt ja gut damit durch. Ich finde das so eine Stelle, mit der man einfach.
Klar, die ist super spannend.
Im Film ist die ja einfach super schnell erzählt und man denkt, oh Aragon, du hast es einfach drauf.
Ja, vor allem, aber es ist natürlich auch. Du hast es einfach drauf.
Du hast es drauf, aber ich finde es auch spannend, wie der Film es schafft, diesen, ja, Prank. Es ist ein Streich. Die spielen den Ringgeistern Streich. also was total albernes, trotzdem bedrohlich und cool dastehen zu lassen und dann aber auch die Reaktion ist nicht, die Trottel haben wirklich gedacht, wir schlafen da, sondern die sind dann alle noch sehr ernst und Frodo knüpft sich so seinen Wams zu. Also ganz merkwürdige Szene eigentlich. Das stimmt. Aber trotzdem guter Film und spannend bis zur letzten Minute. Naja, das war unser... Also, falls ihr ihn noch nicht kennt und die letzten Minuten euch dachtet, was, dann schaut ihn noch gerne an. Der Herr der Ringe heißt der Film, verfügbar auf Amazon Prime, alle Teile auch als Expanded Edition.
Das war die Flo und Hins Film Review-Ecke.
Ich finde es gut, dass uns jetzt aber jetzt jede Folge uns mal gucken, was wäre denn eigentlich, wenn man das nicht weggeschnitten hätte, wir nennen es mal The Cutting Room Floor. Okay.
Das ist ein verquerer Titel für diese sehr einfache Rubrik.
The Editing Suite Floor.
The Suite Suite Editing Floor. Und zwar geht es darum, dass wir dann immer in Filmen, wo Szenen einfach so weggeballert werden, mal gucken, wie sähe es denn da eigentlich aus, wenn man das mal in realistischer Länge zöge. Ja, das ist der große Vorteil von Filmen, dass man schneiden kann. Das merke ich immer mal wieder bei Pen-and-Paper-Rollenspielen, wo du ja diese Schnitttechnik nicht wirklich hast und teilweise sich coole, epische Gespräche leider einfach so verlaufen, weil es ja immer weitergeht und du immer dann so, okay, und morgen reiten wir. Ja, gut, sorgst du dich um das Zelt, weil ich müsste jetzt nochmal los, ich will noch regenerieren und ja, dann keine Ahnung, dann ja, hol du das Zelt, keine Ahnung und weil mein Pferd ist ja ertrunken, kann ich bei dir mitreiten, ja, okay.
Das ist auch im echten Leben.
Das fasert halt so aus alles.
Ja, deswegen fühlt man sich immer so wahnsinnig unkönnen, wenn man sehr coole Filme gesehen hat oder so, mal wieder Ocean's Eleven oder sowas gesehen hat und die einen richtigen Momenten wegschneiden.
Ja, wenn man selber mit jemandem ein gutes Gespräch hat oder sowas, es endet ja immer mit, also auch im Restaurant oder so, oder du guckst
in einen coolen Raum kommen und die haben eine mega Ebene
miteinander und dann bist du selber bei einem Date
und so und hast ein mega Gespräch und da hast du einen Lacher.
Am Ende musst du halt trotzdem noch sagen,
nee, aber ich wollte gerne die Rechnung zahlen. Ja, nee, klar,
alles kein Problem. Wie kommst du gleich nach Hause?
Wir könnten einen Bus nehmen.
Warte mal, in, in, in, in,
aber hier in 40 Minuten fährt einen Bus, den können wir nehmen. Okay. Dann muss man noch 40 Minuten halt überbrücken. Das hast du halt im Film nicht. Der ist ja vorbei. Nee, du kannst du kurz und einfach wegschneiden. Das wäre eigentlich das Richtige. Wie kann man das umsetzen im Leben, dass man einfach sagt, so, besser wird's nicht? Ich mache das häufig mit knallharten Themenwechsel. Knallharter Themenwechsel. Dass es so wirkte wie, man war kurz woanders und kam jetzt wieder in diese Szene rein. Und dann reden sie plötzlich über was ganz anderes. Ihr habt uns Dinge geschickt, denn letzte Woche haben wir euch eine Aufgabe aufgegeben zum Thema Kleinstdialekte. Und zwar hat Stefan erzählt von seinem merkwürdigen interfamilien Code. Du hast erzählt, ihr habt den blanken Montag, den sonst niemand hat und ihr muss es das aufklären in der Familie und wir haben uns gefragt, welche dieser Kleinst Dialekte gibt es noch in der Welt und wir haben tatsächlich viele, viele Nachrichten bekommen, also wenn wir aufrufen zu Spendenaktionen, kommt gar nichts, wenn wir nach Ohrwürmern fragen, kommt gar nichts, aber Kleinst Dialekte, das scheint ein Thema zu sein, das die Leute bewegt und tatsächlich haben viele Leute solche Dinge in ihrer Familie und finde ich teilweise auch richtig gute Begriffe für Dinge, die sonst nicht wirklich benannt sind, das finde ich gar nicht schlecht, zum Beispiel schreibt Nadja, die hat einen interfamiliellen Dialekt und zwar für diese kleinen Hautfetzen an Fingernägeln.
So diese kleinen Hautfetzen, die an Fingernägeln abstehen, die jeder kennt und für dies kein Wort gibt. Nein. Und bei ihr in der Familie, und ich glaube, das könnte sich jetzt wirklich durchsetzen in der deutschen Sprache, weil so entstehen neue Wörter durch Nadja, die sagt, bei ihr in der Familie nennt man die Pips. Pips. Pips? Ich finde dich ehrlich gesagt einen viel zu niedlichen, positiven Namen für etwas, das sehr unangenehm ist, schlecht aussieht und wehtut, aber ein bisschen Pips. Finde ich auch nicht schlecht, dass man sagt, es ist gut. Aber es kommt so im weibsten Sinne unerwünschte Körperfetzen, Popel, klingt ja auch süss. Weißt du, ich finde, in der Reihe macht das schon Sinn, Pips. Ja, finde ich gar nicht schlecht, Pips kann man ja auch ausweiten auf ungewollte Hautfetzen irgendwie, aber vor allem wenn er sagt, du hast ja noch einen Pip, finde ich schlecht. Also Pips finde ich sehr, sehr gut für Hautfetzen, die von Fingernägeln abstehen, finde ich gar nicht schlecht. Hanna gibt uns auch noch einen Begriff, und zwar jetzt würde ich mal gerne fragen, wie nennst du das? Und zwar die Griffe im Auto, wo man sich oben so festkrallt. Der Panikgriff, wo man sich festkrallt, wenn irgendwie schön die Oma am Steuer ist und mit 80 durch die Innenstadt ballert. Da hält man sich fest. Wie heissen diese Griffe? Die heissen, glaube ich, einfach Panikgriffe. Wirklich? Die heissen wirklich Panikgriffe, ja. Wenn du bei VW am Fließband stehst, dann sagst du, ich baue hier die Panikgriffe ein. Das ist der offizielle Name dafür. Ja, Ausstieghilfe vielleicht auch, ne? Das sind ja auch für ältere Menschen, die da nicht mehr so gut rauskommen, die können sich daran festhalten. Hanna hat auf jeden Fall bei sich in der Familie ein eigenes Wort etabliert dafür, und zwar Brückgriffe. Brückgriffe. Brückgriffe, weil die vielleicht so ein bisschen aussehen wie eine Brücke oder so, finde ich gar nicht so schlecht, ehrlich gesagt. Aber ich finde Panikgriff auch nicht schlecht, weil er wirklich nur gegriffen wird. Also wie in der Familie haben gesagt Panikgriff, aber auch weil Opa Herbert immer schwierig gefahren ist. Und Hanna haut noch einen raus und zwar, wenn man was in der Pfanne brät oder generell was in ein Gericht in der Pfanne zubereitet, dann kippt man das aus, dann bleibt noch was zurück in der Pfanne, was sich da so festgebraten hat. Wie nennt man das, weil das ist ja eigentlich das Geilste. Schlick. Dass du das dann nochmal zurück... Schlick sagst du? Nee, aber dachte ich gerade, klingt eigentlich danach. Hanna nennt das Ganze das Gekratze. Weil du das dann noch abkratzen kannst und es ist das Gekratze. Finde ich nicht schlecht. Also Hanna ist auf jeden Fall am Start. Hanna ist vielleicht der neue Shakespeare, der irgendwie 1400 neue Wörter etablierte in der deutschen Sprache. Ab jetzt könnt ihr gerne benutzen Brückgriffe, Pips und Gekratze. Es geht weiter, wir haben viele Nachrichten bekommen. Und zwar Alexander Holz schreibt uns, weil er eine Freundin hat, wie immer das erwähnt werden muss, dass ihr in Beziehung seid. Schön, dass ihr so ein schönes Leben habt. Und zwar sagt seine Freundin andauernd Wörter wie Plastern.
Was könnte das heissen?
Plastern, vielleicht so ganz, wenn man ganz müde ist?
Tolpert sich laufen oder gegen etwas stossen.
Ah, finde ich schlecht. Man plastert herum.
Dann Kodderich.
Oh, Kodderich, das ist so ein bisschen groggy, müde, verkatert.
Flau im Magen, ja, aber gut. Oh, okay. Aber du bist sehr weit, Kodderich, ich fühle mich Kodderich. Ja. Dremmeln. Dremmeln. Dremmeln, bedeutet, wenn man so vielleicht gelangweilt irgendwo auf dem Tisch trommelt. Dremmeln, ja, nee, es ist Drängeln, wo ich sagen muss, ja gut, jetzt sind wir in einem Scheiß direkt. Ja, nee, deine Freundin hat einen Sprachfehler. Gut, da müssen wir die anderen Sachen jetzt auch vielleicht ein bisschen vorsichtig genießen. Knorkeln, was mir unabhängig davon, was es heißt, schon mal einfach gefällt als Wort. Ja, Knorkeln, das sind richtig gute Wörter, ja. Knautschen, sagt er, was von mir dazu führt, dass ich nicht weiß, was es heißt. Knautschen. Aber die Autos haben ja vorher eine Knautschzone. Ja, und wie oft verwendet man das denn? Hast du den Wagen von Rudi gesehen? Der ist richtig eingeknorken. Eingeknorken. Ha, du mit deinen Wörtern. Da müssen wir nur nachfragen, was es heißt. Vielleicht kannst du noch mal schreiben, Alexander. Und grackeln. Wenn etwas nicht fest ist, zum Beispiel eine Türklinke, dann grackelt die. Oh, das ist nicht schlecht. Die grackelt. Wenn es so ein bisschen hin und her grackelt. Knackelt, ja, so knackelig. So ein bisschen knackelig. Was machst du zu einem Wobbly Table im Deutschen? Ja, wackelig. Ja, wackeliger Tisch. Aber so knackeln kenne ich auch, weil man was noch mal so hin und her rüttelt. So knackeln. Der grackelt, der Tisch knackelt. Das finde ich nicht schlecht. Vielleicht können wir weitermachen. Wir drehen es so um, und zwar hat Paula, und du musst raten, wofür das ein Begriff ist, obwohl ich ehrlich gesagt bin mir gar nicht sicher, ob das so in die Kategorie passt, wenn man sagt, meine Freundin sagt immer. Das muss schon was sein, was auch zwischen Leuten selbstverständlich entstanden ist und was man vor allem nicht als besonderes Wort lernt, wo man einfach denkt, es ist ein normales Wort. Weil viele von den Einsendern und Einsenderinnen haben auch geschrieben, ich habe erst in der Uni gemerkt, dass das nicht alle benutzen, das Wort. Das sind die Wörter, die wir suchen. Das sind die Wörter, wo man wirklich denkt, das heißt einfach so. Und zum Beispiel benutzt Paula in ihrer Familie das Wort Pignurik. Und ich möchte von dir wissen, für 10.000 Euro, womit wird Pignurik benutzt? Pignurik. Pignurik. Ich weiß nicht genau, wie man es ausspricht. Finde ich übrigens das bessere Wort für die Hautfesseln an deinen Fingernägel. Vielleicht können wir das umdrehen, dass die Pinjoriks werden. Nee, ein Pinjorik ist natürlich der Flecken, den Türklinken erzeugen. Oh, sehr schön. Weißt du, an Wänden. Ja, ja, genau. Dieser kleine Pinjorik. Das sind Pinjoriks. Wo man einfach sagt, lass uns da so einen Stopper hinmachen, nicht damit mit Pinioriks. Gebrauchsspuren an Türen, von Türen, generell von Dingen, auch wenn man so eine Schublade immer aufmacht und sich schuss irgendwo gegen. Richtig gut. Piniorik. Ja, auch wenn du einen Kühlschrank, der geht auf gegen die Wand oder sowas, Piniorik, finde ich richtig gut. Genau, so Gebrauchsspuren. Paula anders, Paula benutzt das als einen Sammelbegriff für undefinierbare Werkzeuge oder kleine Hilfsmittel.
Also wenn man nicht genau weiß, wie der jetzt heißt, dieser kleine Imbusschlüssel oder was, dann ergibt man den Piniorik, einfach so als Füllwort, als Sammelwort. Und würde auch, glaube ich, funktionieren. Würde total funktionieren. Das sind ja Wörter, wo man oft weiß, was damit gemeint ist, weil sie so von dem Wortklang her schon einigermaßen funktionieren. Finde ich gar nicht schlecht. Angefangen hat das Ganze ja, als ich gesagt habe, dass meine Brüder mir beigebracht haben, für das Innere Weiche vom Brot, Moos habe ich Moos genannt, bis mein Bruder irgendwann gesagt hat, nein, das sagen nur wir so, das heißt gar nicht so. Und interessanterweise hat auch dafür für dasselbe für dasselbe Phänomen hat Ed Einhorst auch ein Wort sich ausgedacht, und zwar heißt es bei ihm in der Familie Plus. Ja, und Plus, also dieses weiche Teige, da ist ein Wortvakuum. Deswegen habe ich nachgeschlagen, wie das tatsächlich heißt, denn rein vom Bäckereifachjargon hat ein Brot nur zwei Teile. Gott simpel. Kruste? Die Kruste, das was aussen knackig, kross und resch ist, und das Innen, was man so rausfummeln kann, das ist die Krume. Kruste und Krume. Es gibt die Kruste und die Krume. Und Kimme und Korn. Genau, also das, was wir als Moos oder als Plus bezeichnen, ist eigentlich die Krume. Also da könnt ihr jetzt das richtige Wort benutzen. Aber wir haben sehr viele Begriffe bekommen, sehr, sehr schön. Zum Beispiel ganz ähnlich wie die Krume benutzt Moritz für den inneren hellen Teil einer Möhre, den Begriff Möhrengold. Ich weiß nicht genau, in welchem Kontext man darüber reden würde. Ich habe einen anderen Vorschlag fürs Möhrengold, was man in keinem anderen Kontext benutzt, wie du schon richtig gesagt hast. Aber man nennt das nämlich, habe ich beim Berufsführerschein gelernt, bei Tauen, bei Seilen, nennt man, gibt es außen die Verkleidung und innen, das kennt man immer von Seilen, dass die aussichtliche Verkleidung so ein bisschen abbröckelt und innen drin kommt dann so ein Kern zu Vorschein. Diese Spirale dann. Genau, ausser so eine Spirale, innen drin hast du einfach so ganz viele kleine, helle Seile.
Und das nennt man die Seele.
Und ganz ehrlich, sowohl beim Brot als auch beim Möhrengold fände ich Möhrenseele, wie so Brotseele, nicht so schlecht die Seele.
Für alles, was innen drin ist, könnte man beim Brot auch machen.
Die Brotseele, dieses schmatschige Zeug finde ich richtig gut.
Einen ganz besonderen, und da hat es Julia ganz gut gemacht, denn die hat noch ein kleines Rezept angehängt. Und zwar sagt Julia, dass bei ihr in der Familie völlig selbstverständlich Cornflakes und Müsli als Phlox bezeichnet wurden. Also man hat einfach gesagt, die Phlox, gib mir mal die Phlox, selbstverständlicher Begriff, erst später hat sie festgestellt, das sagt nicht jeder so. Und sie hat ein Rezept uns mitgeliefert, mal nebenbei. Für Phlox mit Milch. Für Phlox mit Molch. Man mische in gleicher Menge Phlox und Molch, ja. Von Julias Vater, Julias Vater hat das entwickelt, und zwar sind das die Leopardenstreusel. Jetzt bin ich leider nicht so gut im Kochen und kann Rezepte nicht so gut lesen. Vielleicht kannst du mir da helfen.
OZ ist Unzen. Und zwar schreibt sie, wenn die halbe Packung Margarine leer war, wurde sie mit Schokostreuseln aufgefüllt, vermengt und dann aufs Brot gespürt.
Also Margarine und Schokostreusel haben finde ich richtig gut, weil auch bei Nutella oder so ist ja immer noch so eine Butterschicht richtig geil.
Was ich nicht ganz verstehe, ist die Bezeichnung, wenn die halbe Packung Margarine leer war. Was heißt das? Also, dass man eine halbe Packung Margarine... Nee, wenn die Packung halbleer war. Das meint sie? Auf jeden Fall, wenn die Packung halbleer war. Ist das wieder so glashalb voll, glashalb leer Ding, wenn die halbe Packung leer ist? Jahrlich gesagt, in meiner Welt wäre das ein Viertelpackung. Nein, ich verstehe dir nur, was du meinst. Eigentlich gar nicht. Du bist mir da jetzt zu knifterig. Ja, tut mir leid. Ich bin Kniffler, ja. Du bist da viel zu knifterig, weil man kann einfach mal Wörter benutzen. Im Kontext ergeben alle Wörter sind. Absolut. Es ist total egal, was man sagt. Ja. Aber spitzfindig, dachte ich gerade, knifterig. Weil, nee, das ist einfach nur die halbe Packung, meint sie. Die halbe Packung ist leer. Wenn die halbe Packung leer ist. Die halbe Packung ist leer, dann ist die halbe Packung noch voll. Und das meint sie. Das ist unglaublich kompliziert ausgerichtet. Aber das heißt, eine halbe Packung Margarine und dann die andere Hälfte mit Streusel füllen, die dann vermengen. Also Hälfte, Hälfte. Dann wird durchgerodelt und dann kannst du... Und dann hat man die Leopardenstreusel von Julias Vater, kann man dann selber zu Hause nachkochen. Also macht das gerne mal, wenn ihr mal einen gesunden, leichten Snack genießen wollt. Das müsst ihr schon Kochen nennen. Das ist Kochen, ja. Tja, nee, ich finde zwei Sachen vermengen, ohne dass sich der Aggregatzustand wirklich verändert, ist kein Kochen. Also du nimmst die gesamte Welt der Salate raus aus dem Kochen. Ja, Salate sind vermengen, das ist kein Kochen, das ist ein Vermengen. Jesus, Kochen, du musst es ja trotzdem abschmecken. Aber wenn es Backen gibt und Kochen gibt, dann ist Salat machen nichts davon. Das sind einfach Mengen. Vermengen. Was sind deine Hobbys? Mengen. Vermengen. Ich liebe Mengen. Mischen. Nee, nee, nee, ich finde, für mich ist es ab dann kochen, wenn man was vermengt. Weil zum Beispiel Cornflakes zubereiten ist nicht kochen. Du vermengst es mit Milch. Ich vermengst es nicht. Ich tue erst das eine rein, dann das andere. Über die Reihenfolge wollen wir nicht streiten, aber erst das eine, dann das andere. Es wird nicht vermengt. Wohingegen Salate werden vermengt. Und in dem Moment, in dem du mehr Komponenten zu einem etwas Neuem zusammenfügst, du sagst ja vor allem, lass es mich anders argumentieren, es gibt keinen Begriff für das Resultat von Cornflakes vermischen. Du sagst, ich esse Cornflakes mit Milch. Cornflakes und Milch haben zusammen kein neues Wort, wohingegen, wenn du einen Salat machst, es gibt das neue Wort Salat. Immer wenn im Prozess des Zubereitens ein neues Wort entsteht, dann geht es ums Kochen. Wohingegen, wenn du sagst, ich mache ein Butterbrot, ist kein Kochen. Na, aber Butterbrot ist schon ein eigenes Wort. Aber das ist so Hälfte, da kann man sagen, Marmeladenbrot, nee, das ist immer noch kein neues Wort. Das ist kein Wort, aber sobald du ein Sandwich machst, ein Schinkensandwich, dann ist es Kochen. Ich würde sagen, wenn ein neues Wort entsteht, ist es Kochen, wenn du nur sagst, ich esse Flock mit Milch, dann ist es kein Kochen in meiner Sicht. Meine Definition von Kochen ist, du vermengst Dinge mindestens zu einem Grad, wo beide Zutaten nicht mehr unmittelbar als sie selbst zu erkennen sind.
Was hast du denn gegen Salate? Naja, pass auf, nicht per se Salate, mit einem geilen, geilen Dressing wurde, sag ich mal. Das steht so im Tun als Definition für Kochen, spätestens wenn geiles Dressing im Spiel ist. Wenn so ein geiles Dressing mit in die Schüssel kommt, wo man, wie ich gerade sagte, anführe, meine Argumentation wäre, du vermengst Dinge so sehr, dass du nicht mehr sofort beim Draufgucken alle Zutaten selber erkennst. Dann finde ich, weil Sandwich machen ist für mich auch kein Kochen, es ist belegen. Sandwich machen ist belegen, Salat machen ist vermengen. Man muss lauter neue Wörter erfinden, die dann irgendwie da noch Abspaltungen sind. Du belegst ein Brot, so und du erkennst aber noch alle Zutaten, wenn da jetzt aber eine geile Mayo raufkommt, wo du nicht mehr alle Zutaten erkennst, dann hast du die Mayo vorher gekocht. Nein, aber wenn du ein Stück Steak brätst, dann verändert sich das überhaupt nicht. Du siehst, die sieht nahezu genauso aus wie davor. Da wird mit Hitze gearbeitet. Wenn du mit Hitze arbeitest, da ist es natürlich Kochen. Weiß ich nicht. Oder Braten, scharf anbraten. Scharf anbraten, es ist nicht meine Welt, ich bin mir nicht hundertprozentig sicher, aber ich glaube, ich habe ziemlich niedrigere Anforderungen für Kochen, weil ich da einfach schon von den einfachsten Sachen überfordert bin. Und ich mir immer Rezepte rauslege und mir denke, mache ich mal, aber dann mache ich oft nur die Hälfte, mache ich oft, das geht auch ohne Gewürze, das geht auch ohne das. Versuche nur die Basics zu machen und dann schmeckt es furchtbar.
Ganz kurzer Einwand an die Spinatfreaks da draußen.
Kann es sein, dass Spinat nicht mehr schmeckt?
Nee, und zwar, ja, würde ich dir zustimmen,
aber so ganz normaler Spinat, den du kaufst, meinst du jetzt,
im Supermarkt, den du in die Pfanne haust mit schönen Butter?
Seit ein paar Monaten schmeckt mir der nicht mehr. Gar nicht, Ich weiß nicht, warum, gibt es da so saisonale Dinge, dass die ab einem gewissen Punkt im Jahr irgendwie aus einem anderen Land kommen oder so? Also da gibt es doch bestimmt harte Daten, ab denen sich solche Produkte einfach hart ändern. So, aber jetzt müssen wir hier mal ein bisschen empirischer vorgehen, damit wir da jetzt nicht irgendwie so, weil Geschmack ist immer schwierig. Also, kann ja verschiedene Dinge liegen, wir gehen uns mal wie ein technisches Problem an. Das liegt entweder an dir oder an dem Spinat. Das heißt, okay, gute erste Frage, du stellst im Podcast die Frage, geht euch das auch so? Hier kannst du schon mal ein bisschen Meinung aus dem Volke aufschnappen. So, du musst aber auch gucken. Ich rede von Tiefkühlspinat? Frisch einfach Tiefkühlspinat. Aber auch mal überlegen, was hat sich bei dir verändert in der Zeit? Was schmeckt dir vielleicht noch anders? Ich bin auch noch ein Mensch geworden, ja, stimmt schon. Hast du vielleicht zu viel Spinat gegessen? Kurz mal. Ich versuche ja immer, Spinat und Calcium jetzt zu mischen, weil mir jemand gesagt hat, wenn du zu viel Spinat isst, ohne Calcium, dann kriegst du irgendwas. Und hat dir und ist komischerweise, seitdem du Calcium zumischt, schmeckt es es nicht mehr oder was? Nein, das hat nichts damit zu tun, aber irgendwie ist es wie so, wenn so ein ganz schwieriges Gefühl, wenn man sich mit so einem alten Freund trifft und plötzlich merkt, man versteht sich nicht mehr. Wir haben uns auseinandergelebt. Und so ist es mit Spinat wie, das ist immer so ein treuer Begleiter. Wählt Spinat jetzt AfD oder du? Ja, genau das ist die Frage, das ist genau die Frage, wo du einfach dir denkst, irgendwie einer von uns beiden ist vom Weg abgekommen. Und normalerweise ist man so arrogant, um zu sagen, der andere ist vom Weg abgekommen. Spinat. Aber der denkt ja vielleicht auch, mein Gott, was ist aus dem geworden? Spinat will dich vielleicht auch nicht nochmal einladen, irgendwie zu sich zum Videoabend. Mit Sellerie und Lauch. Entweder sind wir vielleicht sogar beide vom Weg abgekommen oder einer und man weiß nicht, wer es ist.
Das kann wirklich sein. Ja, müssen wir herausfinden.
Also meldet euch mal, falls ihr auch die Erfahrung gemacht habt, dass Spinat nicht mehr schmeckt, Tiefkühlspinat, oder falls ihr euch da mit der landwirtschaftlichen Hintergrund auskennt, was da los ist, dann meldet euch bitte, weil ich will wissen, ob ich jemals wieder zurückkomme oder ob ich den aus meinem Handy lösche. Und einfach sagt man, wichtig für Trennungen ist ja auch, dass man klar sagt, jetzt ist vorbei und nicht dieses vielleicht nochmal in einer Woche, vielleicht nochmal in einem Monat. Und da will ich jetzt drüber wegkommen, über diese Angelegenheit und da brauche ich eure Hilfe. Genau, und schickt uns weiterhin eure Kleinstdialekte. Ich finde das super. Ich finde das super. Ich fange an, es zu benutzen. Ich finde das grossartig, wie man so die deutsche Sprache verändern kann. Genau, wichtig, wenn nur, dass man sagt, jetzt geht es nicht um Dialekte, die ihr habt, weil ihr aus dem Ruhrgebiet kommt oder aus Nordhessen oder sowas. Nein, wir wollen ja wirklich Kleinstdialekte, Dinge, die in Familien entstehen, wo man plötzlich wirklich dieses Platons Höhlen-Gleichnis hat, rauskommt in die Echte, wer merkt, niemand spricht so. Das sind die Momente, die wir wollen. Das sind auch die Geschichten, die wir wollen. Da wollen wir ran. Wir sind ja ein Familienpodcast, wir wollen euch an die Hand nehmen. Wir wollen uns an die Hand nehmen und schickt uns das gerne rum. Vielen Dank für eure Nachrichten, vielen Dank für diese Folge, Florian Will. Gerne, war mir eine Freude, vielen Dank an dich und ich wünsche dir weiterhin eine schöne Woche. Wünsche dir auch und wir heben jetzt ab.